Michael morbius discover who
you're meant to be the bat guy
michael what have you done
i was trying to help people
but the cure
it's curse
i have powers that can only
be described as superhumans
but there's a cost now a face of choice to hunt
and consume blood or die we all have monsters
within us it's up to us to control it
what if i can't
michael morbius
you've been given a gift not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be discover who
you're meant to be all our lives we've lived with
death why shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change just accept who you are the bad guy
more bs
holy water really yeah you ever
see lost boys story of my life
Welcome back everyone this is my new morbius
trailer video there's a whole bunch of new
footage and easter eggs we'll break it all down
lots more spider-man references lots more michael
keaton vulture footage and lots more details
about what's actually happening during the film
speaking of spider-man if you're brand new to the
channel i'm doing a giveaway for the spider-man
no way home blu-rays they just announced there's a
whole bunch of extra toby mcguire andrew garfield
and matt murdock daredevil footage on it maybe
we'll get them to release like a four hour cut
of spider man no way home with all that stuff in
it all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know how you think they're gonna cross
morbius over with the mcu we just have to hold out
a little bit more for some more bs versus blade
in the mcu they just introduced mahershala ali's
blade during the eternal's post-credit scene with
kit harrington's black knight when they also kind
of introduced his black knight character in the
ebony blade sure you're ready for that mr whitman
so with any luck after that new blade movie comes
out then we'll hear about morbius versus blade
most of the story in this trailer is morbius
being afraid of his powers and different
forces in the trailer like you have michael
keaton's vulture character kind of yelling at
him in prison to become who he's meant to be you
have matt smith's character also yelling at him
about becoming who they're meant to be he becomes
a version of hunger from the comics but his human
name is milo they call him during the film if
you didn't see my last morbius trailer video i
talked a little bit about what's going on with
his character they changed his backstory from
the comics he is playing a version of hunger who
has pretty much the same powers as morbius but
he's born with the same genetic disorder that
morbius has this is them together meeting for
the first time in the hospital they become friends
and morbius renames him milo they both grow up to
be scientists working for horizon in this building
here that's also from marvel comics morbius is the
one that finds the cure but then eventually after
he gets his powers in milo sees what happens to
him matt smith's character he embraces the
idea of getting these crazy powers doesn't
really care about feeding on people's blood so
he steals the serum gives himself the powers and
then just goes on a complete feeding frenzy then
you have tyrese's character simon stroud who is
also a comic book character from the spider-man
comics the original version of the character is
pretty much what you're seeing on screen here
he was a former member of the cia the nypd
who just went around hunting different spider-man
villains eventually he winds up hunting morbius
but then they wind up having to team up together
to take down a bigger group of crazier vampires
so early prediction is a similar path for their
relationship in the film like he spends most of
this movie interrogating morbius trying to arrest
him but then after matt smith's character becomes
hunger and goes on this feeding frenzy around
new york city killing a whole bunch of people
they probably wind up teaming up because i believe
tyrese said that the contract he signed was for
multiple films so they're trying to turn his
character into a bigger thing the special weapon
device that he's wearing on his arm is also
supposed to come from this universe's version
of oscorp which obviously looks like the andrew
garfield version from the amazing spider-man 2.
one of the few things that they did not put
in this trailer that we actually know about
from the set is the giant spider-man reference
on the bus so there's like a scene of the bus
in the middle of the day where he's learning about
his powers for the first time and everything gets
all blurry on one of the buses there's a giant
daily bugle sign with the tobey maguire version
the daily bugle that says where is spider-man so
it goes way beyond them just showing a version of
tobey maguire's spider-man suit and just making
a bunch of spider-man easter eggs for the andrew
garfield amazing spider-man movies for the tom
holland mcu movies in the tobey mcguire films
they'll probably also be another jay jonah
jameson cameo scene where he's yelling about
a version of spider-man but we'll see how it
goes down because the version that we saw in
the venom let the carnage post credit scene was
only after he'd been teleported into the mcu
so if he shows up during the morbius movie that
also might be the similar situation where we only
see him yelling about spider-man after he comes to
the mcu but because the logo for the daily bugle
on this bus is for the tobey maguire version this
is probably taking place inside morbius's universe
it's the same universe that venom comes from so
regardless they do have a version of spider-man in
this universe who at one point or currently wears
a costume that looks like tobey maguire's costume
but he might not look like tom holland underneath
the costume he could look like toby maguire he
could look like andrew garfield just because
they're mixing and matching so many different
easter eggs from so many different spider-man
movie franchises also really cool daredevil easter
egg here too when he's learning about his powers
really early on that bus that i talked about
where everything gets blurry in the middle of the
day he's standing in front of the chelsea square
diner in new york city that's right here zoom in
enhance on this part of the map of manhattan not
too far away from hell's kitchen now because this
is happening inside the universe that venom comes
from i'm not expecting any huge daredevil easter
eggs during the film i don't think they're gonna
spend a whole bunch of time in hell's kitchen or
anything like that but daredevil did just come
back and spider man no way home and there's gonna
be more spider man no way home references during
this film they also just brought kingpin back
during the hawkeye series a lot of hawkeye took
place in and around hell's kitchen and we know
morbius will eventually make his way to the mcu
maybe in the post-credits scene a lot of you
also asked would he go to the mcu if he did not
know spider-man was peter parker because that was
the whole twist venom came to the mcu because a
version of venom from the multiverse through their
hive knowledge knew a version of peter parker was
spider-man that was the whole reason they used
the hive knowledge name drop across the multiverse
80 billion light years of hive knowledge across
universes would explode your tiny little brain
the tom hardy venom symbiote was accessing the
memories of the topher grace venom symbiote who
knew a version of peter parker was spider-man
and that's why he got teleported to the mcu
there's ways to explain how this version of
morbius in the universe that venom comes from
could see someone referencing a version of peter
parker being a version of spider-man there's a lot
of different ways for that to go down the wyman
sign he crashes through here is a reference to m.c
wyman who's a long time marvel comic book artist
who created a ton of supernatural characters and
worked on the spider-man comics they might be
using some characters or story that he created
in some way for him to get this huge name drop
literally huge because it's a giant sign that
he's crashing through when michael keaton's
vulture is also talking to him in the prison
here in new york city telling him to become who
he's meant to be he's actually trying to incite
him to break out of prison so that he can use the
chaos himself to also escape put together another
version of the sinister six that he's talking
about putting a team together quote unquote
sony is also using the morbius movie to set
up a couple other big spin-offs like there's
a big craven reference during this so obviously we
have the craven movie that's coming next year when
michael keaton's vulture says that he's putting
a team together obviously it's a sinister six
reference jared leto quite literally referenced
the sinister six crossing over mcu crossovers in
one of the last big trailers the film version of
morbius that we're bringing to you now he's also
a part of a much larger universe if you've seen
the last spider-man no way home trailer you know
the multiverse has officially opened and there's
all kinds of opportunities for villains to meet up
thrive and maybe even nurture their more sinister
intents that's all i'm gonna say for right now
that's just sony saying oh we're gonna be doing a
big sinister six spin-off film in the future not
just spin-offs with individual characters like the
craven movie but like an actual spin-off team-up
sinister six film legit sinister six because
there was only five of them during spider-man
no way home and i tweeted this yesterday
is actually michael keaton saying that he's
actually doing some new vulture work that's why he
says new tombs work it's the vulture adrian tombs
in the last couple of days literally and because
the morbius movie still isn't coming out to the
end of the month i think he's talking about
doing some pickups for morbius maybe just some
voice over pickups but he could always be doing
some vulture for some other upcoming spider-man
or marvel related movie just like with the
venom movies i believe sony's plan for the
morbius character long term is that they'll do
direct sequels if the movie does well enough but
they're also going to do a bunch of crossovers
with them the same way that they're gonna try
and cross over venom with spider-man that's why in
the spider-man no way home post-credit scene when
venom came back to his original universe they
left part of the symbiote behind so that they
could do a symbiote saga in the mcu and for all
you lost boys movie fans they actually make a big
lost voice reference during the trailer too bit of
a joke story in my life the lost boys is a vampire
movie about this older vampire taking advantage
of younger kids turning them into vampires the
main characters have to decide whether or not to
be good whether to embrace these vampire powers
become vampires themselves it's meant to be a
parallel for the moral argument that morbis is
having whether or not he's going to use his powers
for bad for good it's the same thing with venom
in the first venom movie we only going to eat
bad people mormies will probably end the movie
deciding that he's only going to drink the blood
and kill bad people and because it seems like
kevin feige is working up to a darker mcu team up
like you have the avengers which are like a bunch
of a-list characters coming together in the movies
it sounds like kevin feige's doing the same thing
with the defenders but with darker characters
on street level with like moon knight yeah blade
we know that kit harington's black knight is going
to be in the blade movie like black knight vampire
hunter if we do see more easter eggs in the next
couple mcu films or even during the morbius film
about some kind of darker hearts of darkness or
midnight suns team up i'll be sure to include
those in the videos that i do if you have
any questions about what's going on with
all the characters just write them below in the
comments and i'll add them to my list of bonus
videos i've got a couple other marvel videos
that i'm working on this week so i'll name a
blu-ray giveaway winner in one of my next videos
but i'll keep doing the giveaway for the rest of
the month till moon knight comes out also really
hoping for a blade or a black knight cameo scene
or reference during the moon night episodes as
well will you wait for everything click here
for that other morbius trailer video with all
the different footage a little bit more footage
of matt smith using his powers too and click here
for that brand new spider-man no way home deleted
scenes video with more tobey mcguire andrew
garfield and matt murdock daredevil footage
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!